escribe cinco y un cuarto como una
fracción impropia y qué es lo que
significa eso de que algo sea una
fracción impropia pues es tal cual una
fracción que no tengan ningún entero al
lado que sea tal cual un número entre
otro número pero que además sea de tal
forma que el numerador sea más grande o
igual que el denominador bueno pero
vamos a empezar por pensar qué significa
eso de cinco y un cuarto tenemos cinco y
un cuarto y eso lo que significa es que
tenemos cinco enteros y una cuarta parte
de un entero que también lo podemos ver
como la suma de cinco enteros más un
cuarto y para verlo de una forma
intuitiva vamos a dibujar unos países
cinco enteros lo podemos representar por
cinco países enteros entonces vamos con
nuestro 1er
y ahora a este país como luego le vamos
a tener que sumar esta fracción que es
un cuarto entonces pues vamos a dividir
estos países en cuatro pedacitos primero
lo vamos a dividir en dos y ahora vamos
a dividir cada mitad en dos y nos quedan
cuatro pedacitos ok un país entero
dividido en cuatro pedazos o sea tenemos
cuatro rebanadas que conforman un país
entero y ahora vamos a dibujar otro pay
y dividirlo en dos y ahora en cuatro y
el siguiente pay
y listo entonces tenemos 5 países que
son representados por este número y de
la misma forma este 5 lo que representa
son 5 países completos
vais completos
completos ahora cada uno de estos países
yo los divide en cuatro rebanadas
entonces cada una de estas rebanadas
podríamos decir que es un cuarto de país
y pues hay que contar cuántas rebanadas
hay en total ahora hay cinco países
cinco países y en cada país hay cuatro
rebanadas entonces para ver el número
total de rebanadas tenemos que
multiplicar la cantidad de país por la
cantidad de rebanadas por país y eso lo
que nos da son 20 ok entonces tenemos 20
rebanadas
pero cada rebanada es una cuarta parte
del país entonces tenemos 20 rebanadas
que representan cada rebanada una cuarta
parte del país ok entonces tenemos
veinte cuartas partes de pan
bueno pero aquí vamos a querer otra
cuarta parte del país entonces lo que
tenemos que hacer es dibujar otro país
y dividirlo en cuartas partes
y quedarnos con una cuarta parte de este
nuevo país y este este
una cuarta parte de otro país porque el
denominador nos dice en cuántas partes
tenemos que partir nuestro país en este
caso el denominador es 4 o sea que
tenemos que partir nuestro by en 1 2 3 4
partes y el numerador nos dice cuántas
de esas partes tenemos que tomar en este
caso nuestro numeradores 1 así es que de
estas cuatro rebanadas solo nos vamos a
quedar con una porque entonces sí
queremos 5 y un cuarto lo que queremos
son 5 países enteros y una cuarta parte
de otro país si dividimos nuestros
países en cuatro pedazos cada uno lo que
obtenemos
veinte cuartas partes de país pero si
además le queremos agregar una cuarta
parte de otro by lo que tenemos son
veinte cuartas partes de un país más la
última cuarta parte de un país esta
fracción está representando a nuestros
cinco países otra forma de verificarlo
es dividir 20 entre 4 y tal cual 20
entre 4 nos queda 5 pero bueno a ver
hagamos esta suma y de eso lo que nos
queda pues como tenemos denominador
común pues el 4 va a seguir siendo el
denominador y aquí 20 más 1 nos queda 21
ok entonces 5 y un cuarto lo que nos da
es 21
cuartos ok entonces cinco y un cuarto
son exactamente igual que cinco más un
cuarto que como acabamos de ver es
exactamente igual que las veinte
rebanadas de cuatro en cuatro en el pie
si quieren las contamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 17 18 19 20 que son
20 rebanadas donde cada rebanada es una
cuarta parte del pay y entonces tenemos
20 cuartas partes del país ok entonces
cinco son veinte cuartas partes más una
cuarta parte de otro país entonces
veinte cuartas partes más una cuarta
parte pues tenemos el mismo denominador
cuartas partes porque tenemos puras
rebanadas que son una cuarta parte de un
país y tenemos veinte por acá y una de
otra
by entonces tenemos 21 rebanadas que
representan una cuarta parte de algún
palo ok
cinco y un cuarto es igual a 21 cuartos
ahora yo lo hice de esta forma partiendo
país y toda la cosa para que hubiéramos
intuitivamente que es lo que está
pasando en el fondo pero hay una forma
muchísimo más rápida para convertir
números mixtos en fracciones impropios a
ver entonces para hacerlo rápido tenemos
aquí nuestros 5
y un cuarto que siempre hay que recordar
que el 5 más un cuarto ahora para
hacerlo rápido esto va a tener el mismo
denominador que la fracción o sea va a
tener aquí un 4 pero en el numerador
vamos a tomar este 5 y lo vamos a
multiplicar por el denominador o sea nos
va a quedar 5 por 4 y luego le vamos a
sumar el numerador de la fracción ok
estamos haciendo lo mismo tenemos 5
países aquí están nuestros 5 países y lo
estamos dividiendo en 4 rebanadas por lo
tanto si empezamos a contar puras
rebanadas tú vamos a tener 5 países
enteros por la cantidad de rebanadas en
las que dividimos cada país o sea 20 5
por 4 más las rebanadas que quedaban
sueltas estas rebanadas
estas rebanadas y la suma de estos
números es el total de rebanadas y para
denotar que son rebanadas estamos
dividiendo entre el número de rebanadas
en los que vivimos cada país o sea 4 así
es quien nada más hay que tomar los
enteros multiplicarlo por el denominador
y sumarle el numerador de la fracción
esto es igual a 5 por 4 20 más 1
cuartos o sea 21 cuartos
21 cuartos que es lo mismo que tenemos
por acá